hong kong is known as asia's world city
but economists are warning that could
soon change the territory is keeping in
line with a zero-covered policy adopted
by mainland china
lockdowns and mass testing are
commonplace and social distancing
restrictions have been extended at least
until mid february
people have been suffering a lot in the
past two years and i doubt whether
people can stand another two three years
uh in the current state so so to me this
is definitely
not ideal
according to a report by the european
chamber of commerce hong kong's
international isolation could extend
into
2024 or until mainland china reopens to
the world
experts say hong kong's reputation could
suffer long-lasting damage given that
you know hong kong is the financial hub
is the headquarters for many
multinational firms in the region
and therefore many experts will want to
come to hong kong but if they're
discouraged by this policy it is going
to make hong kong less international
hong kong is one of the few places in
the world still maintaining its no
tolerance approach to covid and sticking
to mainland china's policy but as a
fifth wave of infections sweep through
the community followed by another round
of restrictions people here are
increasingly questioning whether the
strategy is sustainable or not a scandal
over a birthday party attended by
government officials has done little to
boost trust
on monday hong kong home affairs chief
kasper choi stepped down after admitting
he behaved inappropriately by attending
the gathering last month the government
is also under pressure to boost
vaccination rates among the elderly
currently at just over 30 percent with
omicron infections expected to surge
following the lunar new year festive
period getting infections to zero is
looking increasingly out of reach brit
clinic al jazeera hong kong